so what I love is that you guys are the
first people I think ever to have a lust
trailer I've seen red band trailers I've
seen official trailers I've seen
trailers how do you guys get a lost
trailer how does that happen I have to
be honest with you it's not about me
husband wife I know it's nicer when you
work with somebody you already know and
have a relationship with but I want to
know about the kiss
would you rather kiss a stranger I'd
rather kiss a stranger than a friend
what would you rather do is in and work
with a stranger friend just the kiss
that's a good question
you know what if I were married I'd
rather work with a friend because you've
already worked on set so that knew we
worked on set feeling okay it's not
there okay what do you think okay um I
think it depends on the friend yeah but
I think in this situation here was great
to do with Regina she was left with this
restraining order like three months no
but now I was it you know it really is
it really is work you in this film you
flip a switch you have that ability for
the switch how do you flip that switch
scary man I think the most important
thing is feeling for her is not judging
her because as soon as I judge her I
can't do the things that she does and
make them found it in reality so putting
myself in her shoes what about doing the
kissing scene all of it like the
seduction stuff all of that just made me
so uncomfortable I was filming Paper
Towns when I got cast in the role and I
would turn music on in my apartment and
like look in the mirror and like dance
in front of the mirror like trying to
figure out what actually looks like and
fine try to find my sexy you can do
anything
you want to me so we're gonna have it
you